bonjour annie genevard ou bonjour
président du parti les républicains vous
avez succédé à christian jacob le 1er
juillet dernier vous êtes également
député de la 5e circonscription du doubs
on entendu beaucoup de réactions à
gauche a notamment à ses propos
d'emmanuel macro sur la fin de
l'abondance comment vous à la présidence
de ce grand parti de droite qui ait
l'air vous avez compris cette phrase
nous avons un emmanuel macron très
pessimiste il a délivré un message
sombre et même alarmiste il est un
cassandre lui aussi
est ce que c'est le meilleur moyen de
mobiliser les énergies de susciter la
cohésion nationale j'en doute je déplore
vraiment que il endosse le costume du
déclinisme
je pense que c'est une erreur une erreur
fondamentale que de donner raison à tous
ceux qui voient dans la décroissance
l'avenir du pays et puis je crois aussi
qu'il ya peut-être un peu de tactique
politique
il endosse un costume qu'il affectionne
le capitaine dans la tempête
ce qui lui a plutôt convenue jusqu'à
présent le président qui ne parle pas de
décroissance pour être très précis c'est
pas sa définition de de la sobriété il y
voit plutôt une une économie des
économies d'énergie forcément à faire
avec la crise russe est ce que vous
diriez quand même annie genevard que la
gauche ont fait un peu trop dans la
réaction à cette phrase l'abondance ou
que finalement c'est le signe une fois
encore d'un propos un peu mal choisie
qui peut apporter beaucoup de monde à je
pense que c'est un propos décalés par
rapport à la réalité que vivent beaucoup
de français quand on leur parle
d'abondance et d'insouciance c'est tout
sauf la réalité de l'heure de leur
quotidien mais puisque vous parlez
l'énergie puisqu'au fond c'est une des
questions centrales et du reste des
républicains vont particulièrement
travaillé sur ces questions dès la
rentrée vous voyez emmanuel macron a
fait de la défense de l'environnement un
de ces rendez vous de rentrée et on
relance les centrales à charbon en
france donc tout ça résulte d'une
politique brouillonne en matière
énergétique on a affaibli la filière
industrielle nucléaire qui était une
énergie qui est une énergie décarbonée
et peu chères mais totalement compatible
avec le réchauffement climatique on l'a
vu avec le réchauffement des cours d'eau
certaines centrales sont à l'arrêt ya
énormément de centrales aussi qu'ils
sont à l'arrêt en ce moment pour des de
la maintenance le tout nucléaire de
toute façon n'est pas une solution non
plus à court terme vous feriez quoi vous
rayons mais le mix énergétique personne
ne revient sur le principe du mix
énergétique évidemment mais avoir
affaibli à ce point la filière nucléaire
c'est s'éteint c'est un contre sens
qu'on n'a pas fini que les français
n'ont pas fini de payer moi je pense que
notre situation résulte aussi de
l'absence des réformes qui n'ont pas été
faites qui aurait été tout à fait tout à
fait nécessaire alors dès lors comment
s'étonner que les français soient
actrices soit nostalgique
moi je crois que les politiques sont là
pour donner des perspectives pour donner
un espoir est du reste je pense qu
emmanuel macron comme souvent a été
dépassé par les mots qu'il a utilisée
puisque le soir même il a fléchi ces son
discours dans l'article dans l'interview
qu'il a donnée à challenge c'est
toujours ce en même temps qu'ils nous
aient qui est je crois fatal à la
politique vous demandé plus de clarté
finalement qu'il y ait des choix clairs
notamment en terme d'énergie et que les
français tranche enfin
alors moi je pense que emmanuel macron
doit effectivement
réformer dans le sens qui est utile aux
français et notamment sur cette question
de l'énergie on sait bien que
subventionner l'énergie
aura ses limites gaza a coûté 20
milliards d'euros en 2022
il est évident que c'est une politique
qui ne peut pas tenir à long terme mais
quand il parle de la fin de l'abondance
je vous rappelle qu'il ya pas si
longtemps c'était le quoi qu'il en coûte
dans une expression qui somme toute
résonne très douloureusement aujourd'hui
quand on voit et bien la situation
financière de la france la dette qui
s'est envolé le déficit extérieur qui
est devenue un gouffre abyssal
et puis
l'absence de réformes en matière de
diminution des dépenses publiques en
même temps qu'il parle d'économie les
premiers documents budgétaires que nous
avons pour 2023 montre que tous les
ministères augmentent leur budget
comment voulez vous que les français et
confiance lorsque le président dit les
contes les français ont confiance en eux
ont confiance en nous je ne crois pas
que les français aient véritablement con